hi I'm Eric Voss and venom is now
available at digital HD with blu-ray and
DVD coming out December 18th allowing us
to rewatch the comic book hits during
Tom Hardy Michelle Williams and Riz
Ahmed for all the fun details that we
missed the first time around and dig
into it even deeper with the video
sponsored by then a nice one thing that
caught my attention is the banter
between Eddie Brock and the Venom
symbiote that attaches to him jump yeah
there's a lot of fun [ __ ] chat about
people but there's also a fascinating
power dynamic going on between these two
entities forces either ask the question
who's really in control of this
symbiotic relationship is Eddie Brock
the one wearing the mask and skin of
venom or is it the other way around it's
not that crazy a question like if you're
an alien looking for a human - where's
the skin suit Tom Hardy's a pretty good
option what do you call that up a pout I
guess it works now you might see Eddie
and venom as a classic I hear voices
scenario a symptom of schizophrenia in
which a voice tells someone to think or
do things they wouldn't otherwise do or
think what's cool about Venom's digital
blu-ray release is that it comes with
over an hour of special features a
special venom mode deleted scenes and
behind-the-scenes featurettes and in one
of them you can actually hear Tom Hardy
explain that hearing that voice in his
head it's not only just like that but it
even pushes Eddy's character to decide
what the limits of his own morality are
venom holds at his feet to the fire by
his own ethical framework so for the
first time MIDI becomes the reluctant
hero so we've got a boys trying to
heavily influence a tease action and
he's having to resist them but really
this goes even deeper than schizophrenia
right like this voice is actually a
physically manifesting entity with its
own baggage on my planet I am kind of a
loser like you but here we could be
moving yeah see this voice is too fully
formed too motivated to
three-dimensional to just be a voice
it's an entire personality and there's
another illness known as dissociative
identity disorder formerly known as
multiple personality disorder the idea
is described by the National Alliance on
Mental Illness as a disorder that forms
when someone is trying to escape reality
often because they experienced a
traumatic situation such as abuse as a
result they shift between separate
identities that they form inside
themselves to escape that trauma each
personality may have names traits
mannerisms distinctive voices when the
the switches they experience memory gaps
now I should say that this whole subject
is debated by mental health experts one
of which I am NOT the associative
identity disorder has been a basis of a
number of stories and movies in TV it's
some more respectful than others and
this movie venom doesn't make overt
references to the disorder but there are
certainly parallels that make Eddie
Brock situation a fantastical portrayal
of how di G can afflict people's bodies
their minds their behaviors their whole
outlook look at the moment the two first
spoke to each other face to face this
reflects the way di D patients describe
the feeling of being overtaken by a new
identity that originated from inside
them but before we go too far down this
rabbit hole of comparing Eddie and
Venom's relationship to dissociative
identity disorder let's remember that
venom wasn't born inside Eddie he was an
external alien life-form that found in
bonded to Eddie in the venom digital
release of blu-rays special features
producer Avi Arad described the
relationship this way what I like a lot
is the vulnerability of both but it
recognizes Andy's weakness the moment
he's inside him it will know everything
about Eddie seems that Eddie will never
talk about and remembers split
personalities of di D patients actually
don't know secrets about the other
personalities instead venom is this
outside influence that takes control of
a vulnerable person and pushes them
beyond their inhibitions and yeah really
this relationship sounds a lot more like
a different mental illness addiction Tom
Hardy has said that he actually drew
upon his real-life experience with
mental health and addiction to play this
whole complicated role check out a
conversation between the two entities
later in the film I have absolutely no
problem if you stick them around but if
we do gonna have to have some ground
rules all right you cannot just go
around eating anybody that you want you
whatever you say
but can we get something to eat now
otherwise whoever it's starting to look
really really good so if we look at
venom in any psychology this way this
whole movie starts to look like an
allegory for impulse control in
substance abuse Eddie Brock in the start
of the movie is an impulsive journalist
who crosses the line he breaches his
fiancee stress by exploiting her as a
source he goes off script in the
interview despite being instructed not
to by his boss already Eddie is not in
control of himself is that pulses lead
him to break into the Life Foundation
lab where the Venom symbiote attaches
itself to him and then I'm like
addictive substances is a means of
escape a way to numb you from the world
and make you feel superhuman but also
like addictive substances venom is also
a toxin a force of destruction both to
the outside world and to the hosts inner
world the symbiotes in this movie
eventually kill their host bodies they
feed on their organs and remember in
that clip venom specifically targets the
liver the organ that is actually most
afflicted by alcohol abuse and like an
experienced addict will tell you that
inner voice doesn't ever go away the
impulse will always come back it's a
presence that you have to live with
every day setting boundaries and ground
rules so that you don't completely
surrender control so back to that
question of who's really in control of
this symbiotic relationship well it
changes when venom first overtakes Eddie
venom is clearly in control venom
attacks security guards and the police
officers despite Eddie not wanting to do
that he directly tells Eddie that he is
Venom's ride no more than a horse or a
bird scooter but later the two forces
come to terms with each other venom
accepts Eddie's ground rules
he stays in line he allows Eddie to move
forward with relationships and work in
his career venom won't ever leave but
Eddie is in control and these deeper Ari
watches of venom are exactly why you
should check out the movie on digital HD
and blu-ray Venom's even better the
second time around and all these special
features are fascinating so big thanks
to Sony for sponsoring this video and
letting us react Splore the movie like
this comment down below with what new
detail you noticed upon repeat viewings
of venom following new rockstars on
twitter at new rock stars and me on
twitter and instagram at boss and
subscribe to new rockstars for more deep
dives into venom and spider-man
everything you love right see ya bye
you know what on second thought I think
I'll just take the elevator instead yeah
yeah I know
[Music]